you know what say you're lucky you're
getting a six bad choice i'm sorry
uh you show up at your dad's funeral
what do you mean body count how many
people they've slept with
oh right
tell me about this person so this guy is
andrew tate
top g kickboxing world champion
dozens of [ __ ] at one time he's the
man he has a lot of hot takes he grew up
in the u.s england now lives in romania
dude is a beast and he's taken over tick
tock with like six billion views in like
two months that's cool with his strategy
um so yeah and how many months
like three months wow so today we're
just gonna i just want to see your
thoughts and what you think about this
man who's very well accomplished man
yeah top g
whatever g means and what does that mean
top g the top g he's the man okay um and
tons of [ __ ] tons of [ __ ] i got it
remember that so at one time he has
multiple girlfriends he's very open with
them about
he sleeps with other women but his big
thing is like if he loves you a man
doesn't have to show
loyalty by not sleeping with other women
hey you know what he's honest about it i
think most people there's two buckets
some people are born monogamous i just
happen to be a monogamous person i've
not cheated on men that i should have
cheated on because they were jerks right
but i didn't some people are not
monogamous but everybody lies and says
they're monogamous and then goes around
cheating at least this guy's honest with
himself and everyone around him let's
give him some credit for having
integrity you'll pour champagne and
you'll pass a glass whichever girl you
pass to
you first to pour the champagne and let
them pick up their own glasses you sleep
in bed and you roll over one way hug
that [ __ ]
you never helped me you always had that
i learned to sleep flat on my back
like i could sleep just like boom
[ __ ] here [ __ ]
back i don't move i don't know i wish i
had these problems
no it's no
you're not cut out like that i know you
like to think you are but you're not oh
yeah so one of my old bosses i'm not
gonna say where it was or
but
uh he there were two bosses and one of
them told me about the other one who
lived like tate like he had multiple
women living with him and he was in
serious relationships with both of them
and he had to keep track of
oh this is i can't believe i'm going to
say this in front of you and to you but
he had to keep track of who he came in
last
so that they didn't fight over it
because he would get hell over that
that's gross yeah i actually think
that 19 no no no no i'm going to say
this i think 99 of the world's problems
and no one's going to understand this
but if you can extrapolate but you can
listen to this statement and extrapolate
it out towards society at large
i think 99 of the world's problems will
be solved
if females walk through life with their
body count when they're four
that's a fact what do you mean body
count how many people they've slept with
oh
what what why why do you need to know
the number
hmm
i mean because well what his take is is
that women are emotionally emotionally
attached individuals so if they sleep
with a bunch of men they like lose
i don't know they lose like their sense
of
being able to have like
be as close with the guy and like
they're like i don't know oh [ __ ] all
right four girls flew in i sat them all
down at a table they're all like who's
this chick who's this chick told them
all the truth i just straight sat there
just sat there and said listen
i've been with you all i'm starting a
webcam business i'm gonna get rich some
of you is gonna come with me to the top
of the mountain or if you're pissed off
you can [ __ ] fly so a woman can't go
around [ __ ] people and pretend it's
the same as a man running around [ __ ]
people it's absolutely not the same if i
a man can only cheat if he loves someone
else if i have a woman who i truly love
and i go out and [ __ ] and i come back to
her and i don't care about her and i
only love my girl that's not cheating
that's exercise if she even talks to a
dude it's cheating because females are
emotionally invested see that's where i
i that's like a big stretch like she
talks to a dude yeah
we don't have to agree with that i don't
think this [ __ ] says like no yeah
he's definitely an [ __ ] but i mean
i like the guy no yeah i like him but
everyone thinks he's like an [ __ ] to
an extent
but i don't know i don't know how i
totally feel about like the men can
cheat and woman can't thing because i
know some men who are also emotionally
attached individuals and that get hooked
onto girls like right away yeah and i
know
i mean i know women that aren't but then
i wouldn't want to be with a woman like
that that
that doesn't really like
like fully love you and i don't know
could sleep with other people you know
but then when it's like if she's talking
to other people that's that's just like
dude really
i think because if you truly i mean the
way i see it is like you truly love and
trust a girl
then shouldn't shouldn't she be able to
go out and like talk to people and
absolutely absolutely
but maybe he means talking like having
like late night i'm in bed and texting
flirting maybe that's what he means not
actually just speaking all right i will
not have sons who are too busy buying
nfts and saying oh i made a little bit
money and i have skinny little arms go
to crypto conventions
this one's personal i refuse to add a
nerve during the delay
if my son is a nerd one of us has to die
him or me and i'll challenge him to
mortal kombat no yeah i mean he's not
totally wrong like if you're just gonna
trade nfts and be a little dork like you
gotta be a g on you know you got to be
have your other aspects of your life
doing well
yes but a little kindness could go a
long way like mortal kombat i know he's
exaggerating he laughed after the clip i
just cut it off i know he's i know he's
just being dramatic but
what if his son is just a nerd what are
you going to do
you should have checked the mother's
number well if your son's a nerd it's
kind of your fault as a parent for
raising them to be a nerd you had a
couple little phrases for your little
alex keane
yeah i also played fortnite for like
three and a half years all day
i'm [ __ ] dying
that was a little bit of a geek phase
too mm-hmm
we also stopped pucks with your face so
you had some balance yeah that's right i
bought this coin and it's gone up you
could have bought any [ __ ] coin that
went up in the last year the matrix was
broken i wrote mate put a bunch of
videos out i said the matrix is broken
there's a whole matrix capitalized but
you didn't even capitalized you didn't
listen to it put your meter wages in and
it went up a little bit you thought i
don't have to work anymore yes you
[ __ ] do someone has to cook the fries
dumbass
you need the wages back in their place
no more of these stumps only go up crap
no more of this crypto [ __ ] put the
wages back where they belong it's 9 a.m
you better clock the [ __ ]
nobody can save you but me i'm that guy
you need my help you have two choices
that's about his point and then he sells
this course from there
it's not wrong though no i was one of
the dummies who didn't take enough
profits
when i was at my highs
i learned a lesson but
really isn't wrong everyone can't make
money at once
you know
everyone's not going to make money at
once though
yeah well in the last year everything
went up so crazy everyone was gonna make
money there's a ridiculously high number
of american high school students who get
a diploma without knowing how to read
i'm not worried about who's gonna cook
the fries
i will not administer cpr unless you're
a hot female this is the reality if
you're some fat dude and you've just had
a heart attack and i don't really know
you
100 i mean if you're a really good
friend no not even if you're a friend
you bet if you're my friend you just
can't be a [ __ ] well had a heart attack
get the [ __ ] up [ __ ] wrong with you go
home late have a drink cigarette cup of
coffee
back in the game [ __ ] having heart
attacks near me little [ __ ] facts
facts okay if there's some
skeevy person on the street
and they haven't showered in weeks and
they are killing over and they have that
and they have the you know
that that
white
build up in the corners of their mouth
and when they talk they get the lines
between their lips if uh let me [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna die i'm not giving you
cpr
you
the dog
my list of who gets cpr you give the dog
cpr over a human yeah
oh
over a lot of these events yeah women
can cry men can cry too there's nothing
wrong with it and there absolutely is
something wrong with it and i'll explain
to you why life as a man is far more
difficult than life as a woman and one
of the key components of manhood always
has been and always will be we have the
ability to control ourselves and not act
emotionally females are more emotionally
driven more emotionally impulsive than a
good man should be saying that i felt
like crying so i cried this makes me a
real man is as stupid as me saying well
i felt like smashing his face in so i
smashed his face in this makes me a real
man no the hallmark of a real man is
controlling himself controlling his
emotions and acting appropriately
regardless of how he feels and
throughout human history this is exactly
how men had to live their lives
it's true
a hundred percent i've tried to
incorporate that into my life a lot more
um even like going to the gym every day
you know i don't want to go to the
[ __ ] gym i don't like enjoy going to
the gym
but you know i i
you always want to push yourself and i
want to get girls
yes yes just
wrap yourself in a rubber hazmat suit
when you're hanging out with them
another big thing you've taught me is to
you know not make any decisions when
you're when you're emotional like
especially with big ones like when we
were buying out one of our partners i
you know i had to call you
and you know i had like some crazy ideas
and you know
you gotta you gotta give it sleep on it
and think rationally you know
yeah no emotional decisions no logical
decisions and if you can't control your
emotions in the moment and make a
decision just sit on it and wait you
know there's no need to rush it
yeah
absolutely just moved romanian i had my
webcam company i moved here i had six
girls with me i spent all my money
moving all my stuff out of england and
get germania setting up the house and my
dad i had two choices i said do i either
fly back to the future or do i suck it
up and focus on my business and i missed
my dad's funeral to run my business and
my dad was my hero he was my hero in
every regard so right away what do you
what do you think of that like
absolute
bad choice i'm sorry
you show up at your dad's funeral you
show up to honor him
there's something there's a it's a major
life event that's what i figured you'd
say him
yeah i mean i i feel like whatever would
happen if like my family died i would go
regardless of like if i had to do
business [ __ ] i feel like that's like
way more important i just questioned how
he was raised yeah his dad was his hero
but his dad didn't teach him family
first money is important because we need
it to get through life but family is
first i don't give a [ __ ] his his he he
didn't go to his father's funeral
my sister messaged me that you're so
insensitive i said look i'm my father's
son if he was alive he'd slap me in the
mouth for [ __ ] up my income and
[ __ ] up my chance of building a
legacy for this family and making sure
mom never has to work again to go [ __ ]
to a [ __ ] food i can mourn from here
the day he died i found out at 1 pm 5
p.m i'm commenting on live tv the next
day i'm running my webcam studio was i
devastated absolutely but what did i do
the same [ __ ] well done if he was
okay
going to work
hard enough but i get it if he has
control of his emotions he can stop in
do his tv show do his webcam stuff i get
it you still get on a goddamn plane and
you go to your father's funeral
and you take 24 hours off
no if i oh my god if you don't come to
my funeral i will [ __ ] haunt you
for eternity and your children and your
children's children i'm not kidding okay
let's see
because how i feel doesn't have bearing
on how i live my life everyone knows
what the right decision is you know you
should be in the gym whether you're
happy [ __ ] sad excited it doesn't
matter how you feel you know what you
should be doing so for me i know what i
should do i'm an adult i know i should
run my business i should stay in good
physical health and it doesn't matter
how i feel i know what the right choice
is so i'm gonna make it
so his mother so you weren't there for
your mother you weren't there for your
sister your whole family because it's
not just about the debt it's about the
living at that point
you go for the family you go and stand
next to your mother like a man
at your father's funeral
and you know i i i
i don't even know what to say about this
guy right now i'm so mad
raised by animals i'm sorry you said
your father was a hero no
yeah i mean i i can see both sides but i
definitely agree with you you can see
both sides
what other side is it family first
because maybe if he made that decision
he wouldn't have been able to provide
and take care of his mom like he's able
to now oh that 24 hours was really gonna
set up he lives in in romania and he
would have had to go to the u.s so it
would have been like a multiple week
ordeal
now what have you it's
where's the math the map's on the wall
over there go look at where romania is
where in the it doesn't even matter
where in the u.s i guess you're right
come on there was no he wasn't on pluto
yeah come on i'm sorry nope thumbs down
two thumbs down i'm really mad about
that
for his mother's sake you just ruined it
tate
yeah i'm like i thought you meant i
ruined something no top g ruined it he's
mid middle g now you know i was fine
with all his broads i was fine with
his obsession with money i could deal
with it but not showing up for your
mother at your father's funeral
very cool bro nope
that's all right i'm not going to his
funeral either that's fine
i got i got to walk my dog oh i'm sorry
i've got i've gotta
cook the fries
somebody's gonna cook the [ __ ] fries
i need to talk to him i do i need to
talk to him we'll get him on the pod one
day teach him about family
and priorities maybe he needs you know
what
he needs to come to church with me
yeah
we'll fix him he goes to church actually
surprisingly enough
yeah the church of tate
the church
because his
take on emotion like turn it off and do
what he got to do but he wasn't saving
lives you know what i mean if there was
like a little kid if he was ben carson
and he was
taking siamese twins who were connected
at the brain and separating them because
he was the most brilliant brain surgeon
on earth and that was the only day he
could do it that wouldn't matter
this hanging out with the six broads no
they could have won the show well
overall what would you give tate one to
ten
he was gonna get an eight he's down to
at least a seven i know it was six i'm
sorry he's like
you know what tate you're lucky you're
getting a six because you didn't go to
your father's funeral i'm sorry
yeah and i don't and
you're more like a four really but i'll
give you a six because you won some big
titles and and you you otherwise seem
like an entertaining
guy he's an entertaining guy
well
that was fun
make sure to subscribe um there'll be a
lot more of this coming
so
are you buying the wine next time yeah
sure all right thanks i'll leave my own
glass
[Music]